more than 50 of those aboard the plane
were Canadian their passing has been
mourned at a number of memorial services
the Foreign Minister summing up the
impact on the country this ladies and
gentlemen is a national tragedy a
sentiment echoed by the Prime Minister
he insists the Iranian admission of
responsibility should not end the
investigation earlier this morning I
spoke with President rouhani of Iraq I
told him that Iran's admission that its
own Armed Forces unintentionally shot
down flight 752 is an important step
towards providing answers for families
but I noted that many more steps must be
taken a full and complete investigation
must be conducted the president of
Ukraine initially had this to see on his
Twitter feed acknowledging plane shot
down is a step in the right direction
I insist on immediately completing
identification of the bodies and they
returned to Ukraine the perpetrators
must be held accountable but then in a
national address the president ordered
Ukraine's prosecutor to open an
investigation
yes o'clock I've seen about maryville
grain I call on all international
partners of Ukraine the entire world
community to be warned and persevere in
the full and final investigation into
all the circumstances of this disaster
all of us need it later on Saturday the
first reaction from the White House and
two tweets in English both repeated in
Farsi the president referencing protests
in Iran insisting he's always stood by
what he called the brief and
long-suffering Iranian people and will
continue to do so
adding we are following your protests
closely and are inspired by your courage
Trump has also called for human rights
groups to monitor the protests telling
Iran the world is watching but from
nowhere in the Trump administration and
what appears to be a coordinated
response has there been any direct
comment on Iran's admission that it
don't the jet Alan Fisher al Jazeera
Washington